>> IT LOOKS CLEAR RIGHT NOW THE
FIRST OR SECOND WEEK IN JUNE TO
GO INTO PHASE ONE.
MANUFACTURING, CONSTRUCTION,
WHOLESALE, AND RETAIL ONLY FOR
CURBSIDE PICKUP.
THOSE ARE THE BIG STANDARDS, AND
THEN WE WILL FILL IN A LOT OF
BLANKS BETWEEN NOW AND THEN
ABOUT HOW TO DO THOSE THINGS AND
HOW TO APPROACH THEM SAFELY.
BUT I THINK IT’S GOING TO BE
FIRST OR SECOND WEEK IN JUNE,
UNLESS -- UNLESS PEOPLE GET
UNDISCIPLINED AND START TO LOSE
TRACK OF THE STANDARDS, AND WE
START TO SEE A RESURGENCE.
>> Neil: YOU COULD ALMOST HEAR
ALL OF NEW YORK CITY’S BUSINESS
AS SAY ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
THE NEW YORK CITY MAYOR,
BILL de BLASIO, DRAGGING THE
SHUTDOWN OUT.
PARTICULARLY TO YOU WHEN HE
WANTS TO DO THIS.
THE FIRST, SECOND, MAYBE THIRD
WEEK OF JUNE.
THEY COULD BE DONE ENTIRELY.
CONGRESSMAN, WHAT DO YOU THINK
OF WHAT THE MAYOR IS SAYING?
THIS IS STILL SOME WEEKS OFF.
>> YET, MY FRIEND, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR HAVING ME.
LET’S THINK ABOUT THE SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER RIGHT NOW.
THE GUY WHO OWNS A SHOE STORE,
FOR INSTANCE.
FOUR MONTHS HAS SEEN THE LIQUOR
STORE OPEN, OKAY -- AS IF THE
LIQUOR STORE HAS SOME ABILITY TO
HYPNOTIZE COVID BEFORE IT COMES
INTO THE STORE TO STOP IT, BUT
THE SHOE STORE DOESN’T.
LET’S BE SENSIBLE.
THE MAYOR’S COMMENTS ARE COMING
OFF AS IF HE IS AN ELITIST
DILETTANTE THAT DOESN’T
UNDERSTAND THE STRUGGLES OF OUR
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS.
YOU KNOW, WE CAN DO THIS
RESPONSIBLY, BUT WE HAVE TO HAVE
THAT SENSE OF URGENCY.
AROUND THE MOMS AND POPS THAT
HAVE DEDICATED THEIR LIVES TO
THESE BUSINESSES.
I COME FROM A LONG LINE OF SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS, AND I
UNDERSTAND, JUST AS SO MANY
NEW YORKERS DO, THAT IS NOT A
95.
THAT IS YOUR ENTIRE LIFE.
THEY ARE WATCHING THEIR SMALL
BUSINESSES WHETHER ON THE VINE.
WE HAVE GOT TO DO SOMETHING.
ISSUE STANDARDS, DISTRIBUTE PPE
AND A MASSIVE WAY, AND LET’S
START TO GET THIS THING OPEN.
MOST SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS ARE
INCREDIBLY SMART.
ESPECIALLY IN NEW YORK CITY.
THEY UNDERSTAND THAT 25%
OCCUPANCY RATE, THAT’S JUST THE
BEGINNING.
TIMES ARE STILL GOING TO BE
REALLY DIFFICULT, BUT AT LEAST
IT’S A START, AND THEY ARE
DESERVING, IF NOTHING LESS.
>> Neil: YOU ARE A
UNITED STATES CONGRESSMAN, SOUTH
YOU CAN WEIGH IN AND MAYBE TRY
TO INFLUENCE THE MAYOR, BECAUSE
IT DOES SEEM TO BE CIRCULAR TO
THE GUIDELINES WE ARE HEARING
FROM NEAR GOVERNOR CUOMO.
WHAT IS HE LOOKING AT THAT
OTHERS ARE NOT?
INCIDENTS?
HOSPITAL RISK, ALL DRAMATICALLY
DOWN IN THE CITY AND ALL THE
BOROUGHS.
SO WHAT IS HE BASING THIS ON?
DO YOU KNOW?
>> WELL, LOOK.
I AM NOT GOING TO SAY THAT WE
SHOULDN’T BE LOOKING UP SCIENCE
AND WE SHOULDN’T BE CONSULTING
METRICS AND TRUSTED EXPERTS IN
THIS REGARD, BUT WHAT I THINK HE
IS NOW LOOKING AT, WHICH IS THE
CRITICAL THING -- WE KNOW HE’S
LOOKING AT HOSPITALIZATION AND
THIS AND THAT, BUT WHAT HE IS
NOT LOOKING AT IS THE POTENTIAL
FOR A CONTINUED ECONOMIC NUCLEAR
BOMB TO GO OFF EACH AND EVERY
WEEKEND NEW YORK CITY AS OUR
SMALL BUSINESSES, OUR MOM AND
POPS DIET.
AT THEIR CUSTOMERS RIGHT NOW GET
TO GO TO TARGET.
THEIR CUSTOMERS GET TO GO TO
HOME DEPOT.
TWO LARGE SUPERMARKETS, AND THEY
CANNOT GO TO THE SMALL
BUSINESSES.
IT DOESN’T MAKE SENSE.
AND ALL WE ARE ASKING FOR, ALL
THEY ARE ASKING FOR IS SOME
SENSE OF GUIDANCE AND SOME SENSE
OF URGENCY THAT GIVES THEM
RESOURCES --
>> Neil: THEY ARE NOT GETTING
IT FROM THE MAYOR, CONGRESSMAN.
>> NOW, THEY ARE NOT, AND THAT’S
A PROBLEM.
>> Neil: SOME OF THEM ARE
ALREADY OPENING UP, SO I’M
WONDERING, TECHNICALLY, THEY
WOULD BE IN VIOLATION OF THE
MAYOR’S ORDERS AND BY EXTENSION,
THE GOVERNOR’S ORDERS.
FOR THOSE WHO MAY FEEL TEMPTED,
I’M GOING TO OPEN UP, ALLOW
SIDEWALK SERVICE, SHOULD THEY BE
PENALIZED FOR DOING THAT?
>> LOOK, MY FRIEND, I’M NOT
GOING TO COME ON YOUR SHOW AND
ADVOCATE FOR ANYONE TO BREAK THE
LAW OR GO AGAINST THE MAYOR’S
GUIDANCE, BUT WHAT I AM COMING
ON HERE TO SAY IS THAT THIS
MAYOR’S LEADERSHIP AT THIS
POINT -- MESSAGE IS PITIFUL, AND
THIS CITY WILL BE BETTER OFF
WHEN HE IS NO LONGER THE MAYOR.
THIS IS AN ENORMOUS
DISAPPOINTMENT, AND OUR
BUSINESSES ARE GOING TO SUFFER.
NOW, THERE ARE CERTAIN THINGS,
THOUGH, THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT CAN BE DOING AS WELL.
I CAME OUT SAYING THAT THAT
PRESIDENT SHOULD BE PUSHING PPE
DOWN TO OUR SMALL BUSINESSES.
WE HAVE TO EXTEND THAT PROGRAM I
ASKED OF THE EIGHT WEEK DEADLINE
TO 24 WEEKS, AND WE CERTAINLY
HAVE TO GET RID OF THIS
RIDICULOUS 75/25 RATIO.
IF YOU’RE A SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER, YOUR RENT IS SOMETIMES
50% OF YOUR COST.
WE HAVE TO FIX THAT SO THAT THEY
CAN STAY OPEN.
>> Neil: LET ME ASK YOU THIS.
THE PRESIDENT AND HE WAS PUSHING
THAT HOUSES OF WORSHIP OPEN.
I TALKED TO A RABBI AND A PRIEST
ON THIS ISSUE, SAYING THAT THEY
WILL OBVIOUSLY HONOR REASONABLE
CAPACITY REQUIREMENTS, BUT THEN
THEY COME OUT WITH A STATEMENT
SAYING WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
CLOSELY WITH PHASE LEADERS TO
ENSURE THAT PEOPLE CAN SAFELY
WORSHIP.
BUT WE WILL NOT TAKE STEPS THAT
WILL JEOPARDIZE NEW YORKERS
HEALTH.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS THEY
HAVE NOT BEEN SUPPORTING LARGE
GATHERINGS IN CHURCHES.
THEY HAVE NEVER BEEN DOING THAT,
SO OBVIOUSLY, THEY ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO HONOR WHAT THEY HAVE
ALWAYS BEEN DOING, WHICH IS NOT
WHAT THE PRESIDENT SO THEY
SHOULD BE DOING.
SHOULD YOU AND DO YOU HAVE
PROBLEMS WITH ANY PEOPLE OF
FAITH, ANY HOUSE OF WORSHIP,
ONCE AGAIN, RETURNING TO THOSE
PLACES OF FAITH, EVEN HONORING
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND OTHER
GUIDELINES THAT WE HAVE SEEN IN
OTHER STATES?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
LOOK.
YOU LOOK BACK THREE MONTHS OR SO
SO, THE PRESIDENT’S I ACTUALLY
CORRECTLY NOTED THAT OPENING AND
CLOSING SHOULD BE DECISIONS MADE
ACCORDING TO DECISIONS BY
GOVERNORS.
THIS IS A DECISION THAT CANNOT
BE MADE ON A NATIONAL BASIS AND
HAS TO BE MADE IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH OUR FAITH-BASED LEADERS.
LOOKING AT THESE ORGANIZATIONS
IN NEW YORK CITY, I THINK THERE
IS AN OVERARCHING CONSENSUS THAT
WE ARE NOT YET AT THE POINT
WHERE WE CAN BEGIN TO OPEN, BUT
WHAT WE SHOULD START TO DO IS
TELL PEOPLE WHEN IT WILL HAPPEN.
I REMEMBER BACK TO WHEN I WAS AN
ARMY RANGER SCHOOL.
THE WORST THING THEY CAN EVER DO
TO YOU WAS NOT TELL YOU WHEN IT
WAS GOING TO END.
THAT WAS WHAT I FEARED MORE THAN
ANYTHING ELSE.
AND THAT IS THE PLACE THAT MOST
NEW YORKERS ARE IN RIGHT NOW.
THEY’VE BEEN DOING THE RIGHT
THING.
THEY HAVE SAVED LIVES.
NOW THEY HAVE TO BE TOLD WHEN
TIMES CAN GET BACK.
>> Neil: CONGRESSMAN, BE SAFE,